we were supposed to be watching a movie
in Kenny's room we were watching there
was a movie playing man but we had snuck
out that's what it was but then they
were like no more movie
sean gets to watch the movie on the sofa
bed and I'm like okay and I remember the
movie it was the first home alone right
um you out there just laughing out loud
no no I was out there just like well
life is how could this get any worse oh
the next morning when I wake up having
hosed the water bed or the sofa bed
full Sprout like I'm talking
late Sean you know what I mean just like
a full-on like shot so now not only do
they all hate me but the parents
hate me so I'm just like the most hated
12 year old
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Music]